you
hi everyone is Jerry there's a trap for
black out of the two Knights defense
that can catch the white side who tries
to land a fork on this f7 square with
the King Knight and the King Bishop
converging so let's see how we can
address such an idea
efore e5 Knight f3 knight c6 and already
from move three white points at the
weakest square f7 once
knight Knight to f6 the two Knights
defense and now Knight to g5 so clearly
we need to be doing something about this
d5 interferes with the communication on
f7 e takes d and now I've seen a few
replies here by black one is to take on
d5 which is going down the fried liver
attack Road we're not going to cover
that nor are we going to throw any
direct punch at the bishop with b4 or
Knight to a5 I've seen this before
this particular line and also Knight to
a5 going down this road here we're not
going to cover any of those three moves
Knight takes pawn b5 or Knight to a5
instead we're going to try Knight to d4
simply centralizing our Knight and
setting a very small trap one where well
clearly we're not throwing a punch of
the bishop and so white may very well
think there is time to clear the way to
simply clear the way and get back on
this F 7 squared directly now before I
get into what we can be doing in
response to d6 let me just point out
that maybe the best move for white is to
simply do something about the knight
that's in the white position with c3 and
what you can be doing as a reply is b5
if the knight is taking you take the
bishop and well we go down a very messy
Road one where white is up upon but we
do have the bishop pair that does count
for something and if instead of pawn
takes Knight if the bishop plays here we
can be developing like so if Bishop
takes were there to recapture it's an
interesting position and if the bishop
goes home this is one that I thought to
be quite interesting as
I was reviewing for this video we can
take on d5 allow our Knight to be
captured because we have a counter
attack on g5
so if pawn takes Knight Queen takes
Knight if Bishop takes pawn King to d8
something needs to be done about g2 if
castles there's a few interesting moves
for black here this is the one that I
found most interesting Bishop b7 because
it's setting up something very deadly
the best move is probably Queen f3 looks
a little bit scary to place it opposite
the bishop but just to highlight how bad
things can get for white something as
natural as Knight to c3 will now be a
mate in 4 with Knight to f4 three pieces
hitting g2 and you could only make
computer-like moves to delay the
inevitable the main point here is that
we're threatening mate with Queen takes
g2 and if this pawn moves knight h3
that's me and so you can only do moves
like Bishop c6 and Queen to f3 these
pieces are just getting taken and again
it's still the same story if this pawn
does not move from G to Queen takes g2
is mate and if it does move Knight h3
game over the main focus however of this
video is this position right here where
we don't have the best reply but instead
one where white is looking to finally
crash through on f7 by playing d6
well what do we do here we simply take
the pawn there's two different ways to
recapture I'll cover both if Bishop
takes pawn with check we play to e7 and
keep pressure on the bishop we're now
threatening h6 to kick away the knight
and win the piece the bishop needs to go
away we take the bishop pawn takes we
give the knight a kick we give them
another kick and unfortunately the best
he can do is go back home if he's going
elsewhere such as h4 we move our King to
f7 we wanted to go there anyway we're
defending against the fork we're also
threatening g5 to win the knight black
is doing very well in this position so
the other line is going to be the one
that white has been hoping
for since move three they finally got
what they wanted
they've landed the fork the rook and the
Queen are hit and it's very easy to
overlook Queen to see six simply
sidestepping the threat against the
Queen
counterpunch against both Bishop and
pawn after Knight takes rook Queen takes
pawn hits the rook rook to f1 that's the
only safe Square for the rook and now
unfortunately for ye after Queen to e4
you'll either have to give up the queen
or the king queen to e2 we simply take
the Queen and if Bishop to e2 that's
game over
I think many players as black would be
thinking Bishop g5 is a bad move because
there is this potential in between shop
Bishop takes Knight and now what do you
do is white